واحد من اصل 10 ناخبين توجه الى صناديق
الاقتراع في الشوط الثاني من الاستحقاق
التشريعيه بنسبه مشاركه بلغت
11.3% الى حدود الساعه السادسه وبعدها
جميع مراكز الاقتراع سجلنا تصويت
87 الف
638 ناخذ اي بنسبه 11 فصل 3% من عدد
الجمله للمسجلين طبعا
اللي هم
753,000 و 447 هذه النسبه قلت هي نسبه
دقيقه مع هامش
وفي سؤال للعربيه الحدث عن اسباب تراجع
نسب الاقبال على التصويت اكد المسؤولون عن
هيئه الانتخابات انهم قاموا بكل ما يلزموا
لانجاح الانتخابات مع ضروره البحث في
الاسباب هذا التراجع اكيد عنده اسبابه
واسبابه اكيد متعدده سياتي الوقت ربما
للتقييم ويجب ان يكون التقييم علمي واا
موضوعي
عمليه التصويت في مختلف الدوائر تمت بشكل
عادي اما من توجه الى مراكز الاقتراع
فقالوا انهم ينتظرون ان تعود ثقه ويتم
القطع مع المنظومه القديمه لابد من المضيء
الى الامام هذه فرصه التاريخيه لن تتكرر
بفرض ارادته والقطع مع المنظمات القديمه
اللي حشتنا بها تسترجع الثقه وقت اللي
يقول كله تونس بالفم والاملاء على التونسي
ان يبادر على التونسي ان يقوم همم ما هو
واجب عليك
لتتحسن الاوضاع
وينتظر ان تعلن النتائج الاوليه بدايه
الشهر القادم على ان تعلن النتائج
النهائيه في شهر مارس اصغر المقبل
وبعد حسن المصاري التشريعيه في انتظار
استكمال الطعون والاعلان عن النتائج
النهائيه تتوجه الانظار صوب تركيز
البرلمان الجديد بوصفه اخر محطه في المسار
الاصلاحيه والقطع مع المنظومه القديمه
وليد عبد الله العربيه
تونس